people of the internet's retrorecontour
here and surprise surprise i'm back with
yet another hogwarts legacy rumor update
but we also have some legit news as well
that could possibly speak to the game
getting a little bit closer maybe look
i'm gonna be honest with you guys i
always appreciate when you send me the
rumors so hit me up on twitter when you
see any of this stuff at retrorecontour
but at the same time like so many of you
i'm just kind of over this i haven't
been making a video on every single one
of these little rumors because let's be
honest there have been a lot lately but
it's just sort of the same kind of stuff
over and over again we saw a rumor
recently about the possibility of maybe
some mini games being included with some
multiplayer elements i've been
predicting this for a while now i think
there's definitely going to be some kind
of multiplayer component but it's all
just guessing i mean let's be real here
it's people with some maybe a little bit
of credibility online is having some
leaks right in the past but overall it's
not like some super reliable source that
we're getting all this stuff from now
there is one in the form of a job
posting that we're going to be talking
about but let's start with all of these
other rumors that have been coming about
first up there are a number of sources
who seem to be indicating a sony state
of play event in february and
potentially a very big state of play
event this is something that's not just
coming from one person online i've seen
this from a number of different folks
and let's be honest here i mean it's not
really that outlandish to say that
there's going to be a sony state of play
event soon i mean they do these things
periodically throughout the year they
had their big holiday push and now we're
kind of settling into the new year
february would be a perfect time to kind
of say hey here's the games coming out
over the next couple of months and it
also wouldn't be a surprise to see
hogwarts legacy i mean let's be real
here guys we heard directly from
avalanche right at the end of 2021 they
outright said look there's more coming
on the game we can't wait to share more
with you in the new year the new year's
here as far as we know the game is still
on track to release this year so it only
makes sense that we're going to start
getting some information soon which i
know you all are very excited about i
mean it's a very exciting time but as
always with these rumors i mean take
them with a grain of salt there was
another rumor that was talking about hey
the game is probably going to be
releasing much sooner than people expect
i mean stuff like that guys just
you can't put much stock in it because
these people have no idea trust me on
this because i actually work in
marketing my day job is in marketing
it's nothing related to the video game
industry but i know
how these dates get pushed around even
internally when you have something
that's coming up you may have a date
that you feel is like your rock solid
date hey this is when we're launching
this product or this is when we're going
to push out this release and that may be
the date for months and months and
months and then like two weeks before it
happens you have something come up where
you have to adjust it maybe if it's even
by a day so it is my hunch that not even
within avalanche and not even within wb
do they know the exact precise release
date of the game yet sure they probably
have a target one but that could totally
change based on how these next few
months go so anything that starts to
deal in specifics like that i'm always
immediately very sort of cautious about
believing that i have maintained for a
while now that i think it's gonna be a
holiday 2022 game i would love to be
wrong i'd love for it to be even sooner
than that this summer who knows maybe
even like march i mean just be insane i
don't think there'd be enough time for a
big marketing push if that were the case
i'm still expecting late this year but
as far as hogwarts legacy being at a
sony state of play in february yeah i
could totally see that i hope that's the
case we're in 2022 now guys it's no
longer the state of avalanche not saying
anything at all they've actually talked
about it and said hey more news is
coming now let's deal in some concrete
information for this next one here
avalanche has posted yet another job
listing and this one is particularly
interesting because it is for a
localization producer so i'll put it up
on screen here i'm not going to read
every single bit if you want to pause it
and kind of read over all this i
definitely encourage you to do that but
just hitting the high points here
localization is one of those final
things that is done in a game i mean the
game pretty much has to be done for
localization to really take place
because what happens with localization
is they take the game as it's built and
then they essentially translate it to
all the different other languages for
where the game is going to be published
now this doesn't mean the game is coming
out like tomorrow because yes
localization takes time and as the job
posting even mentions there are a lot of
different regional
stakeholders that are sort of involved
here and there's a lot of work with
localization that needs to be done but
the fact that they are posting for this
that they are hiring for this that tells
us that the game is getting closer which
is certainly a good thing i know there
are still some of you out there who
believe the game is never coming out i'm
not one of those people i think it's
absolutely coming out and i really do
guys i really do think we are getting
close to actually starting to get some
concrete information so we don't always
have to do these little news videos
where it's like hey here's another
little random rumor or a job posting
hopefully fingers crossed hopefully we
are getting closer now in the meantime
if you're someone who loves the old
school harry potter games then you have
to check out my latest video i'll post
it here on the right side of the screen
it is the complete history of harry
potter video games or if you just want
to get caught up on all the latest
hogwarts legacy news then check out the
video on the left side of your screen as
always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon